[Music]  he has had a tremendous year  michael bryce the bodyguard of the year  [Laughter]  is he a relative of yours god no darius  kincaid's a  hitman wanted for like a zillion murders  around the world and how often do you  have this dream  just once well that's not tonight right  i'm thinking you need to forget  bodyguarding  [Music]  i'm officially on sabbatical and to be  honest i don't know why i didn't do this  sooner  [Music]  this is the world's been waiting for me  to make this change  for the first time i'm starting to  imagine a life without bodyguarding  this really feels like a newbie  could i know you  that means no guns no killing and no  blood  what is he doing here  are you using pepper spray i'm on  sabbatical  i would make a great mother don't you  think oh my god a child would be so  lucky to have you as its host  [Music]  you're gonna tell us everything you know  i'm not telling you  i on the other hand will tell you  everything  [Music]  you